comment transporter des milliers de
personnes sur l'ensemble de l'île de
france au moment des jeux olympiques
comment gérer des déplacements nombreux
les évolutions technologiques et de
transport devront voir le jour comme à
saint quentin en yvelines
supra ouais c'était c'est un pour nous
c'est un modèle idéal pour justement
résoudre nombreux des problèmes évoqués
qui sont entre autres la possibilité
d'avoir un transport trait sur 24 heures
sur 24 aux tonneaux c'est une amie qui
se trouve à grande échelle qui aussi en
parler avec le grand paris express
typiquement c'est des grands projets qui
sont
autant bénéfique pour les jeux
olympiques que pour les parisiens à
terme les franciliens à terme le
transport de foule sujet de prédilection
dalenc rakovic directeur général de sncf
transilien invité principal de la
conférence organisée par l'estac a
transporté aujourd'hui 3,5 millions de
voyageurs par jour en fait on est le
deuxième système de mass transit de
ferrer du monde derrière tokyo
mais on sait que l'île de france va
encore augmenter et puis on s'est
finalement qu'on a besoin de
s'intéresser aussi aux autres mégapoles
dans le monde dans 60 ans on aura des
mégapoles de 80 millions d'habitants et
notre conviction c'est que aujourd'hui
seul le ferroviaire peut répondre à ce
défi à l'estaca la filière ferroviaire
est présente depuis 25 ans une
quarantaine d'étudiants la composent
chaque année la conférence était une
occasion de susciter des vocations
on considère que globalement il ya à peu
près 50% des métiers de les cinq à dix
prochaines années qui n'existe pas
encore donc on essaie d'anticiper ce
mouvement et donner une orientation très
orientée vers le futur
le transport ferroviaire est aujourd'hui
encore en mutation avec des projets
comme l'hyper loupe qui vise le
transport guidé jusqu'à 1200 km heure